all right this is also from the daily
wire it says fashion magazine marie
claire
wants to see more parents getting
abortions on network television and in
films
using the popular left-wing obsession of
representation the 84-year-old
women's publication ran an article on
july 16th worrying that if more women
who are already mothers don't see
characters like themselves killing their
unborn children
they might not choose to do so as well
and that would be
what a tragedy that would be does that
mean that more more children are born we
can't have that
author danielle campemore who also
has written for the new york times
washington post and vanity fair promoted
her piece on twitter saying
parents are the most common abortion
patients it's time we see
ourselves having abortions on screen in
the story she argues
countless studies have highlighted the
importance of representation in the
media be it race gender relationships
body size and shape mental health or
disability status
the same is true of abortion but
accurate depictions of the most common
abortion patients
parents is still severely lacking you
know
the thing that stands out about about
this to me
is uh yeah it's it's deranged and
twisted that you want to see more
abortions on screen at all
whether you want to see any abortions on
screen in the first place
but think about that she says well the
most common
abortion patients quote unquote are
parents
but we don't see but anytime there's a
story involving abortions
in a in a movie or a show it's not
usually it's not a parent getting the
abortion
and that's a problem for this writer
well hang on a second
no no let me correct you it's not that
parents are the most common people to
get abortions
it's actually that by definition every
single person who has ever gotten an
abortion
is a parent that is exclusively
going to be parents every single person
by definition because if you're getting
an abortion it means that you're a
mother
and that's not semantics at all this is
not this is not splitting hair that's a
that's a
very important point
because that this is the message that
they're kind of sneaking in here with
something like this
forget about all the stupid stuff about
representation
the message is that if you
are a woman and you get pregnant and you
don't have any other kids who are born
then you're not a mother yet you're not
a parent you're not a mother or a parent
until the baby is born
and so if you go and and get an abortion
then you you're you're not a parent
you can remain not a parent
but that is not the case once you
the moment that your child comes into
existence
you are a parent again by definition
you have offspring that that's what a
parent is look it up in the dictionary
and so the moment that the child is
conceived comes into existence as a
physical
entity distinct from yourself
another organism which is what a child
in the womb at any stage
the child in the womb is a separate
organism biologically scientifically
and that that organism is your offspring
you are the parent
the mother and as i have
uh tried to communicate
many times and not not as a way of of
not even as a as a way of of heaping
guilt or anything just as a
as a um
[Music]
as a simple observation
when you get the abortion you don't go
back to not being a mother you are now
the mother of a dead child
i think that's very important to realize
something has happened here in the
conception of that child
that cannot be undone and that's the lie
that they get
from the abortion industry
you know they what they're told is that
is that pregnancy
is this kind of no man's land um it
gives you nine months to just decide
you you don't have a kid yet and if you
decide that you want the kid then then
magically now you are the mother
but it's a it's a it's kind of a
nine-month return policy sort of
situation
that's not the way it goes in conception
something has happened that cannot
cannot be undone a life has come into
existence you can kill that life
but you're still a mother now you're the
mother of a dead child
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated